إنه
لشرف لي أن أكون جزءًا من هذا ، ومن دواعي سروري
لكل مسلم يعيش في هذا
المجتمع
[موسيقى] أن
كل رسالة يمكن لكل مسجد في
مينيابوليس الآن
بثها بصوت عالٍ بالطبع ،
يُسمح بوقت [الموسيقى] من الساعة 7 صباحًا حتى 10 مساءً.
ليست المرة الأولى التي
سُمح فيها أيضًا لمدينة مينيابوليس
بوجود مسجد واحد في منطقة المحيط الهادئ في منطقتي
تم منحه تصريحًا خلال السنوات الثلاث الماضية فقط خلال
شهر رمضان
[موسيقى] ،
ولم نواجه أي تحديات على
الإطلاق وكان هذا شائعًا جدًا في  في المجلس
كان لدينا 13 عضوًا في المجلس بالإضافة إلى توقيع رئيس البلدية
، لقد كان الأمر وفقًا لسرعتنا على
الرغم من وجود الكثير من التعليقات الإيجابية
التي تلقيناها حتى الآن من المسلمين أو غير
المسلمين
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أن كل مجتمع يجب أن
يكون قادرًا على
وضع سياسات  تعكس أه
السكان في المجتمع لذا
من الرائع أنها أخبار رائعة
وأنا متحمس حقًا
وخاصة
قبل أيام قليلة من إجازة شهر
رمضان
[موسيقى]
أنت